just before we move on I must say to you
because it's been such a weird year
because the Oscars and and all the
controversy and everything
so and it must be offer you talking
about it because you're kind of part of
it if you know any people to hear your
performance that movie so where you
officially now where you standing you're
not the thing that's most important for
me is that that the spirit of it has to
maintain there's the the media sort of
creates the the the US and Neb and for
me there is no us and then it's we you
know I'm a member of the Academy you
know so I felt very seriously that
there's a sort of a kind of a regression
that in America in general a regression
towards separatism and racial and
religious exclusion so for me it's more
about putting my hand up and you know
reminding my community the Hollywood
community that we have to lead that you
know diversity is America's superpower
you know that's that's what what makes
our country great and it's really
important in Hollywood we've got to be
pushing forward even in a time of a
wider regression well hopefully
something good comes out of it it always
does yeah as my grandmother said that's
the only thing that can come out of it
you if you leave with love and light
good is only gonna come out of it
wise man
sir Don Johnson Miami Meister like that
feeling home all the time pres my wife
not since never you know it's that voice
that in world / fear